i don't know how many of you are going
to believe this or not but it is very
true
there is talk
of hillary clinton
2024.
let that sink in
they are talking about hillary 2024
again and what we are seeing is that so
far
in the midst of what's going on with
covid
and
an understandable frustration with lack
of more
tangible accomplishments among many
joe biden and kamala harris are being
increasingly seen as
uninspiring
unexciting
and vulnerable in 2024 vulner and i've
said before this part i agree with
completely i've said in 2024 if trump's
the nominee
or if desantis is the nominee
i don't feel super confident about biden
versus either of them
and if biden says i'm not running for
reelection but here's kamala and kamala
is basically awarded the democratic
nomination i also don't feel very
confident about that some who share my
concerns are saying
let's look at bringing hillary back the
idea being
in hindsight so this this is this is the
case some are making i'm not making this
case the case i'm making is listen the
american public now knows what a mistake
it was to choose trump over hillary so
what better way to put a democrat back
in the white house than to say
now do the right thing with hillary i
think this is potentially disastrous
there is a very interesting article in
the wall street journal which full
disclosure uh the the wall street
journal
is part of news corporation fox news etc
this is an op-ed by doug shone and
andrew stein
and it's called hillary clinton's 2024
election comeback joe biden and kamala
harris have become unpopular it may be
time for a changed candidate now you can
agree with part of this and not all of
it let me tell you what i mean by that
joe biden and kamala harris have become
unpopular when you actually look at the
average of approval ratings
joe biden's actually doing okay it there
is no mathematical case
that joe biden is really unpopular as
you can see
biden's approval came down significantly
in late july
through september and into october but
since then it's basically basically been
steady within one point and it is not
unusually low if you look as 538 allows
you to do if you look at how biden
compares with past presidents biden is
more popular by about six points at this
point in time than trump was during his
presidency
um and he's
sort of close to others i mean
you know i think the exception certainly
with george w bush at this point in time
bush had the he was buoyed in his
approval by by 9 11.
uh joe biden is less popular right now
than obama
clinton george h.w bush reagan nixon
uh ford is very very close and and less
popular than jimmy carter that's true
but compared to trump he's actually
doing better so for me
the approval rating right now is not
really the signal
about whether joe biden can or cannot
win in 2024 but what this is a signal
about
is that there's no question
that it's hard to look at the biden
harris administration and be excited now
to some degree they were handed a very
difficult situation when it comes to the
pandemic
but this is less about popularity today
per se
it's more about
the vision for what do things look like
after the midterms
what is it exactly that this
administration is going to stand for or
accomplish and to some degree the reason
people are talking about hillary
is that there aren't many inspiring
figures in the democratic party that
people are excited about for 2024.
i know that there's let me go through
some of the contingents there's a
contingent that says
it's bernie's time
i believe bernie's time has come and
gone i don't think a third run from
bernie is going to be what inspires the
democratic party to come together and to
defeat whoever is the republican in
2024.
i just don't see it and i know some of
you disagree with me i love bernie i
just don't think bernie at what whatever
age he will be
um bernie sanders age
uh bernie is
80 so he would be what 80
uh 82 82 83
83 84 when he would become pre i just
don't see it and you can apply the same
thing to biden and that's fine i
wouldn't disagree with you i think that
there's an issue with biden's age as
well i don't think that that's what it
is there's another side that says
there's no one more exciting than aoc um
i think it would be really tough in 24
for aoc to run for president would she
even be old enough that's another
question when
will aoc be old
enough to run for president
um
she turns 35 a few weeks before election
day okay so she may be eligible i have a
really hard time imagining that aoc is
going to win the presidency in 2024
despite a lot of people being very
excited about her so then you end up
with people saying stuff well what about
warren budege and it makes a lot of
progressives cringe even though when you
look on paper warren's one of the few
people proposing a wealth tax something
very popular with the progressives uh
buddha judge is one of the few guys who
can actually consistently
uh out rhetoric whoever it is he's
talking about fox news host whatever but
it doesn't feel like it's going to
really inspire what the widest swath of
the democratic party so
i get why people are again saying i
don't know maybe hillary again
she's younger than some of these other
people
but it strikes me as potentially
disastrous let me know your thoughts you
can find me on twitter at dpakman we'll
take a break and be back right after
this it is a brand new year maybe you
have goals around getting in better
shape maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to
magicspoon.com pacman and use the promo
code pacman